[Musique]
c'est le moment de faire le point avec
mélanie poquet pour découvrir deux
nouvelles sorties juniors cette semaine
mélanie vous allez nous parler de danse
pour les parents et les enfants et
d'exploration c'est ça tout à fait c'est
un dimanche 1er octobre charge et
camille il va falloir faire un choix
alors pour le premier rendez vous la
compagnie pernette et la ferme de bel
ébat de guyancourt vous invite à un bal
un bal en trois temps de la danse libre
un moment où la chorégraphe nathalie
pernette de même la danse est aussi un
temps de repos pour récupérer en
admirant les danseurs de la compagnie
c'est l'occasion de se faire plaisir et
de partager un moment en famille de
voilà de créer de la complicité entre
les parents et les enfants
ça peut être aussi entre les grands
parents et les petits enfants les oncles
les tantes et les neveux et nièces voilà
c'est familial c'est ouvert à tout le
monde ya pas de prérequis il faut pas
avoir fait trois quatre ans d'école de
danse municipale pour venir tout le
monde tout le monde peut venir
j'ai envie de dire dès l'âge de 4 5 ans
napper solide derrière je suis et c'est
à dire en même temps et cela me projeter
dans l'espace social
[Musique]
après
alors l'entrée est assez 0,80 elle
comprend le bal mais aussi un goûter
traditionnel d'antan pour profiter de
cet après midi rendez vous à la ferme de
bel ébat à 15h alors un autre rendez
vous pour les plus téméraires dimanche
il s'agit d'une chasse au trésor cette
fois oui c'est ça les apprentis
aventuriers devront se rendre au village
seniors orpea saint rémy l'idée de ces
là aussi de faire participer les enfants
les parents et les grands parents
alors jennifer caron la directrice du
centre nous explique la mission a relevé
alors le roi henry 14 a bien caché de
potion magique auquel il tient
énormément mais il a quelques troubles
de la mémoire et sachant qu'il avait ces
troubles de la mémoire il a dissimulé
des indices au sein de sa cour
l'idée étant au jour les participants de
rencontrer les personnages qui sont
qu'ils font partie de la cour du roi
afin de pouvoir leur soutirer les
informations et d'obtenir tous les
indices et leur permettent de retrouver
ce trésor qui est très bien caché et
donc des défis et des épreuves à réussir
alors parents et grandfonds voix et
grands-parents parmi les réviser votre
culture générale
les enfants vous devrez prouver votre
agilité votre adresse tout le monde peut
participer là aussi ces deux là c'est
dès l'âge de 5 ans une participation de
3 personnes 3 euros par personne est
demandée et les fonds seront reversés à
l'association imagine fort margot pensez
à vous inscrire et surtout n'hésitez pas
à vous déguiser puisqu'il y aura un
concours du plus beau déguisement qui
conclura la journée un concours du plus
beau costume merci mélanie pour ses
différentes idées dans son aventure à
vous de choisir des informations pour y
participer s'affiche au bas de votre
écran